les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 en octubre Brasil
Elige a su nuevo presidente son comicios
muy polarizados entre el izquierdista
Luis Ignacio lulada Silva y el
ultraderechista Yair bolso y durante
esta campaña electoral hemos visto a
muchos artistas brasileños tomar
posición no es una dinámica nueva en
Brasil pero es que el peso de las voces
de los artistas cambio de es que hará
estos últimos años gracias a las redes
sociales el candidato que logró ganarse
los votos de las figuras más conocidas
del país es sin duda el expresidente
Lula primero la estrella de la pop y del
francarioca Anita la cantante brasileña
más escuchada a nivel internacional que
en internet como en sus conciertos o
durante entrevistas se posiciona como
una férrea opositora de bolsonaro sigue
después una mezcla entre artistas
recientes y muy populares como la drag
Queen Pablo
que apoyan históricamente a la izquierda
desde la dictadura militar del lado de
bolso hay menos artistas y menos caras
famosas fuera de Brasil pero algunos
cantantes que hacen parte del estilo de
música muy popular que es el sextanillo
el country brasileño como Gustavo Lima
se convirtieron en apoyos muy firmes al
actual mandatario un fenómeno que nos
explicó el historiador Paulo César Gómez
lo escuchamos
los artistas en general Especialmente
los músicos que apoyan a bolsonaron
que es una cultura más conservadora del
campo
por lo que para bolsonaro Es bueno tener
públicamente el apoyo de este tipo de
cultura
Claro que siempre hemos tenido artistas
de derecha que apoyaban por ejemplo a
los dictadores durante la dictadura
brasileña pero ahora desde 2013 más o
menos vemos el extrema derecha estar
orgullosa de sí misma
en un momento en el que tenemos internet
la televisión en el que tenemos varios
tipos de medios de comunicación pues la
voz de la extrema derecha se ha hecho
mucho más poderosa y accesible al
público
las voces de los artistas se vuelven
políticas cuando apoyan a partidos o
personalidades pero también de momentos
de crisis lo que estamos viendo
últimamente en irán con el caso de la
joven kurda masamine a pesar de una
violenta represión por parte del
gobierno las protestas por su muerte
siguen encendiendo el país y dentro de
las personalidades del deporte políticos
y religiosos que expresan su enfado en
las redes sociales los cineastas y
actores iraníes están especialmente
comprometidos incluso los más grandes
Alison
nos cuentan más
es un llamado a la solidaridad de uno de
los cineastas más célebres del mundo
asgar faradí ganador del Oscar por una
separación publicó este video en las
redes sociales mientras las protestas
arrecian en su país
multiplica todos los artistas cineastas
intelectuales activistas de los Derechos
civiles de todo el mundo y de todos los
países a solidarizarse con las valientes
mujeres y hombres de Irán grabando
videos escribiendo o de cualquier otra
forma
un llamado que escucharon otros miembros
de la Industria cinematográfica a iraní
en una carta abierta piden a todos los
cineastas del mundo que apoyan las
protestas y que se hagan Eco del grito
iraní por la libertad
la misma lucha está llevando a cabo una
actriz que se hizo famosa por su papel
en la serie los anillos de poder enumera
las formas de ayudar a los iraníes desde
el extranjero
exija su representantes que hablen de
las violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
en Irán ya que no hay posibilidad de
rendir cuentas en el país en segundo
lugar organizan manifestaciones frente a
la embajada iraní en su país y la hay y
que el gobierno iraní sepa que las
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos no
quedarán impulsas
la industria cinematográfica iraní
también está en el punto de mira de las
medidas represivas del gobierno en mayo
y junio los directores mohamma rosuloff
y safar panai fueron encarcelados la
razón aducida su activismo supuestamente
opuesto a la revolución de 1979
éramos Este programa con los estrenos
musicales que nos llamaron la atención
esta semana empezando con la Banda
alemana de pop profundidad
reconocemos la guitarra falk y la
rítmica suave que caracterizan a Milky
James anunciar la salida de su próxima
mixtape 2
y en el planeta tierra francofono dos
poderosas figuras del género estrenaron
su quinta colaboración el francés kalash
y el belga danzo que quieren alcanzar
las estrellas con el tema mal polisondo
[Música]
Nos despedimos con Apolo la luminosa
nueva canción del nigeriano Víctor y
gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en 24
y 24.com
[Música]